before we're done tonight I'm gonna try
to tell you what I think of the three or
four things that have to be done to save
our country and I'm going to claim that
they can be done and I'm going to claim
that the model of them is in the
lincoln-douglas debates but tonight
before he has to go away and vote no I'm
going to introduce to you Tom cotton so
um Thomas Bryant cotton is the junior
senator from Arkansas
he's a sixth generation Arkansas raised
on a cattle farm in Dardanelle in the
western central part of the state and if
my family could count to 6 we would
claim the same thing but we too have
been there for a long time and that
means that Tom cotton and I are first
cousins
he graduated from Darden Allen high
school and then in 1998 he graduated
from Harvard College and then later from
Harvard Law School and then later from
the Claremont Graduate School where I
got degrees myself in 1977 he was a
publius fellow at the Claremont
Institute where I was working in the
President there and that's when I first
met him and I have never lost touch with
him and think great things are coming
from him I'm going to say that one of
the things that we need is statesmanship
and that it's rare and hard to find and
that the elements of it are a
combination of what Winston Churchill's
wife called deadliness I've always
envied him that Churchill my wife is a
wonderful woman and for reasons but
unbeknownst to me attached to me
but she's never written a letter to the
head of the country saying that only my
husband has the deadliness to fight the
Germans now Tom himself is married to a
beautiful woman and happens that my wife
and I knew this woman before he did and
my wife especially had some agency and
bringing them together and he is not
worthy of his beautiful Anna has given
him a boy Gabriel of lay but his nearest
can be among the male population and
what's he like he's a Harvard lawyer
from little town in Arkansas he's a
partner at Gibson Dunn & Crutcher and he
stops all that and joins the army and he
makes the army commit to him before he
goes that he's not gonna be a lawyer in
the army he's gonna be in the infantry
and he patrolled the streets in Iraq for
two years and then later set up
reconstruction and counterterrorism
center in Afghanistan and one the Bronze
Star doing it even the old guard in
Washington he got out he went to
consulting for McKinsey & Company and
then he quit that and you know it gives
him done in cruncher in a McKinsey and
company salaries are very high and this
is a boy from a little town in Arkansas
the son of a cattle farmer he doesn't
have any money what he does have is an
older sister in my F Nidal who's a
lawyer and who does his taxes and she
adores him and in the Arkansas sister
way I have two of them she expresses her
adoration by criticizing him constantly
and her particular criticism of him is
that just when he gets himself twice in
his life in a position to make a lot of
money he quits and he goes into public
service so the second time he ran for
the Congress
United States he won handily and I'm
forgetting Tom was missing Arkansas the
former Miss Arkansas the candidate
against you in the Congress yeah so he's
coming out of nowhere and he's a former
soldier and he's a lawyer and he's gonna
run for Congress and former Miss
Arkansas was running against him and I'm
from Arkansas and I thought wow Tom can
you beat her and Mike Huckabee had
endorsed her and I thought this is
reckless you know but then I saw a
photograph of her in the bloom was not
quite all that it had been and he wanted
a landslide and that in the next term he
runs for the Senate against the priors
and you know the prior family in
Arkansas I grew up with them coming into
politics and Mark Pryor know who's an
extremely you know is an intellectual
and a man of principle he's a really
nice fella
and Tom beat him by 18 points an
incumbent in an old Arkansas political
family I said deadly mess it takes
something else because just like in our
own lives we have to be effective we
have to get things done we have to
encounter opposition and overcome it
milder than in war but the same thing
I'm not so in our own lives there's
something outside the necessities that
we each face every day that calls to us
and says that we have to be in the right
and especially in politics with these
choices are the hardest
right the classics somehow you have to
find a way to take it stay and
and be able to articulate the largest
things and the eternal things and it's
very rare for somebody to be able to do
that and it never happens except that
somebody lives his life in the right way
I mean all of it and for years
blessed with great talents and yet what
they want to do is they want to learn
and they want to school themselves to be
prepared for the greatest occasions and
I don't know anybody in politics who's
done that better than the senator from
Arkansas Tom cotton
thank you thank you thank you all very
much for the warm welcome and Larry
thank you I think for the kind
introduction if I were to spend my
remarks correcting though all the
embellishments and exaggerations and
outright calumny in that introduction I
would have no time for other remarks so
I'll simply point out one mistake that
Larry made I was a fellow at the
Claremont Institute of which Larry was
the president in the summer of 1997 not
the summer of 1977 which is the summer
when I was born into this world I will
confess however that that Larry and
Penny as well as David Bob another
member of the Hillsdale family here
tonight did play an instrumental role in
introducing my wife Anna and me for many
months before we met they had mentioned
her to me told her after the 2012
elections that there might be some hope
left but not every person who had won
the election that year starting most
particularly at the White House was no
good for the country and then through a
long sinuous turnover the answer that
she would tell you if you were here that
would involved vouching for my character
and research and getting reassurance
that I wasn't a typical politician for
whom she has no great love lost she
finally met me I will tell you since she
is not here to correct me that I gave a
speech and a pretty redhead came up and
gave me her phone number afterwards
it's a hundred percent true well I want
to again thank you all for the honor of
addressing you tonight at your
Constitution Day celebration I admire
and I share your veneration for our
national charter unfortunately I can't
say the same about the gentleman who
lives across the street in the last week
President Obama has moved ahead the
nuclear arms control agreement with a
mortal and unrepentant enemy with the
support of only a rump partisan minority
in the Congress some have compared his
nuclear deal to Obamacare but I think
that's unfair to Obamacare at least it
had a partisan majority this dangerous
turn of events offers an occasion to
reflect on the state of foreign policy
today and the Constitution's place in
our foreign policy a major preoccupation
of foreign policy elites over the last
25 years has been to forge a new grand
strategy for the United States scholars
and practitioners tend to see a foreign
policy adrift after the fall of the
Soviet Union when containment of Soviet
expansion became obsolete overnight
seeing no major ideological or military
rival some believed that the owl of
Minerva had taken flight and the end of
history reduced the need for strategic
thinking
unfortunately that fantasy came crashing
down along with two big towers 14 years
ago last Friday again foreign policy
elites search for a new strategy this
time for the age of Islamic terror now
circumstances do change in foreign
policy which is often a matter of
prudence must change with them to
achieve the same ends Alexander Hamilton
for instance invented our tariff system
and Hamiltonians defended it for more
than a century yet today they're the
most ardent of free traders so the
effort to develop a strategy for our
times is welcomed in fact it would be
nice if we had a strategy since this
president seems to confuse ideology with
strategy which he frequently admits that
he doesn't have
still I'm struck by a certain blind spot
a blind spot that goes to the heart of
this way of thinking too often the
search for a new grand strategy simply
becomes the search for something new
this way of thinking carries a hint of
disdain for the principles and the
foreign policy traditions of our past it
only rarely looks back on the wisdom of
our founders but this is a mistake
as I don't have to tell this audience
after all when the makers of kids
breakfast cereals rolled out a new
product they call it new and improved
because we all know the former doesn't
imply the latter in every case likewise
every new and fashionable idea and
foreign policy isn't necessarily an
improved idea
on the contrary we ought to pay some
respect to the old ideas ideas that took
us from a small and weak colonial
outpost to the greatest superpower in
human history in just a 170 years with
that track record common sense would
suggest that there's something special
that we can learn about charting our way
in this world from the Constitution's
and the strategies that our roast from
it our founders gave us a constitutional
democracy a system of government that
informs our foreign policy just as much
as it does our domestic policy for many
foreign policy elites especially those
abroad this is the serious problem with
u.s. foreign policy democracy empowers
the people these critics say who they
believe can be ignorant emotional and
fickle swinging wildly from warmongering
to isolationism from moralism to
callousness far better they say is what
Walter Mead is called the auteur theory
of foreign policy guided by a brilliant
strategist insulated from the unruly
masses one hears the echo of this
viewpoint in the praise for what these
critics see is the coherent and decisive
strategic thinking of men like Vladimir
Putin as ji Jinping Putin is praised as
a brilliant strategist one who is
redefining 21st century warfare she has
been called a game-changer in China's
rise one
International ambitions and power rivals
that of Mao Zedong and Dijon pink modern
China's most influential leaders now
admit that Putin adji may have stolen a
march on our president here there that's
an indictment of prison Obama's
abilities and policies not our system of
government by the traditional measures
of international influence economic
might for capital well-being military
and trade cooperation agreements
cultural weight the United States far
outpaces both Russia and China as well
as the rest of the world and while a
brooding auteur may in fact have
strategic foresight intellect and
prudence no man of course is infallible
no matter how talented Napoleon growing
in general that he was still marched his
army into Russia Otto von Bismarck
toiled for decades to unify the German
states only to see his fragile work
undone a few years later wilhelm ii
militarism and adventurism and in the
same way past leaders and regimes have
faltered i believe that over time putin
and g to say nothing of kim jong-un and
the ayatollahs in tehran will also
miscalculate suffer strategic setbacks
and ultimately face their own downfall
but the United States is different from
these regimes our constitutional system
doesn't depend on brilliant leaders
thank goodness enlightened statesmen as
Madison wrote will not always be at the
helm our system is based on individual
rights safeguarded by well-crafted and
ultimately democratic institutions while
we always hope for wise leaders our
Constitution works in their absence by
filtering the wisdom of the people
through those democratic institutions
this approach couldn't be more at odds
with the auteur theory of foreign policy
from that perspective our system looks
like some kind of policymaking
Frankenstein Authority is divided
between the executive and the
legislature the executive itself is
divided into
p-ting departments the President and
sent Secretary of State Shore to serve a
short tenure compared to the Kings and
the ministers of the old world equal
representation of the states in the
Senate gives considerable influence to
regional interests and the arcane rules
of the Senate along with the separation
of powers itself simply slows the whole
process down how could this thing ever
work yet it has again again the talent
of a single leader or small group
without size control over foreign policy
can never match the moderation prudence
and self-correcting capability of our
constitutional democracy over the long
term and in international relations it's
the long term that really counts in the
realm of domestic policy these ideas are
familiar our constitutional system works
to ensure that all the individuals
interests factions lobbies and others
who influence or who are influenced by
domestic policy are more or less
satisfied or perhaps minimally
dissatisfied the same thing plays out in
foreign policy as well
Americans for America's foreign policy
tradition is flexible agile and
multifaceted and that therefore tends to
produce positive results for us in a
complicated world again though I can't
stress how alien and unfashionable this
way of thinking is in Foggy Bottom the
West Wing to say nothing of European
ministries among many foreign policy
elites these democratic influences are
something to be suffered and overcome as
we've seen most recently in the debate
about the Iran nuclear deal an end
though we usually survive mistakes by
particularly ders because leaders are
not the foundation of our system the
foundation of u.s. foreign policy is
that the use and the values of the
American people filtered by elected
representatives through democratic
institutions proven over time
of course this foreign-policy tradition
is not an accident when designing the
Constitution the founders are very
conscious of the need to invest the
federal government the strong foreign
affairs powers while accounting for the
interests of the states and the people a
driving force behind the Constitutional
Convention was the failure of the
Continental Congress to manage the
Foreign Affairs of the young Republic
this imperative was clear in the
ratification debates and the first five
papers of the Federalists are devoted to
the necessity of blunting the influence
of foreign powers into the organization
of US military power and a full 15
papers of the Federalists are focused on
international relations in civilian
command of the military against this
background the Constitution could be
understood not only as a strategic or as
a national charter but also as a
strategic document the institution's
established by the Constitution channel
the conduct of foreign policy that
channelled the conduct of foreign policy
implies certain principles of foreign
policy we ought to keep these timeless
principles in mind as we craft strategy
for today's world one principle found in
the Constitution is so simple that it's
usually overlooked the states are
stronger as a union than as separate
powers a union of the states overcame
the divisions culture economic interest
in military capacity divisions that
would have been exploited by foreign
powers to turn one State against another
and weaken encou the American continent
to their designs a union strengthened
the collective power of the states in
their Foreign Relations it allowed them
to pull their various resources and to
create advantages of scale and scope and
military economic power as Federalists
for States Union and good national
government is necessary to repress and
discourage war further if our national
government is efficient our trade
prudently regulated our militia properly
organized and disciplined our resources
and finances discretely managed our
credit reestablish our people free
contented and united foreign powers will
be much more to dispose to cultivate our
friendship
than to provoke our resentment
conversely if the state's word is
divided we would earn the contempt
before nations and eventually their
outraged and outsized influence this
principle came under threat but survived
during the Civil War in his first annual
message to Congress President Lincoln
sent a clear warning to foreign powers
to refrain from interfering in our war
at the same time he acknowledged that
fascist domestic division exposed the
nation to what he deemed disrespect
disrespect abroad and eventual foreign
intervention we may take this principle
for granted today but it's very much in
play around the world the European Union
for example has a greater combined
population and economy than the United
States political divisions however
greatly reduced the EU role in world
affairs
the smaller nation-states of Central and
European and in Eastern Europe in
particular find themselves at risk from
or perhaps at the mercy of Russia
likewise the countries of the Asia
Pacific region from South Korea all the
way around to India worried about
China's aggressive drive for regional
hegemony if they struggle with their own
enmity and rivalries to form a strategy
to counter China's rise the primacy of
Union under a constitution gives rise to
a second and related principle treaties
with foreign powers are very serious
business ought not to be entered lightly
and must be widely supported across the
country the founders believe the
violation of major foreign commitments
was a chief source of friction and war
in international relations in fact
Federalist three recognizes just two
sources of war direct violence and the
breach of treaties thus the Constitution
requires that a major foreign commitment
that binds our people have a broad
consensus among the people and not
result from the parochial interests of a
minority or even a narrow majority as
literal matters of war and peace treaty
should reflect a strong Union not a
divided nation
this principle led to the treaty clause
which empowers the President to
negotiate treaties but constrains the
president by requiring two thirds of the
Senate to approve them and if necessary
demand changes this extraordinary
requirement is really just an ongoing
expression of that original decision to
form a union and it's produced a system
where treaties routinely go through many
iterations and rounds of negotiations
even after initial signature by the
president
Trudy's throughout our history carries
scores of conditions reservations and
amendments added by Congress precisely
to ensure widespread acceptance among
our people this was in fact how the
first treaty ratified under the treaty
clause played out the Jay treaty with
Britain negotiated by co-author of the
Federalist only gained Senate approval
on the condition that Jay reworked the
treaty to add a clause regarding trade
between the United States and the
British West Indies another principles
that the Union must have a strong
military but one that at the same time
is restrained and subject to the control
of the people at the founding a powerful
and restrained military was something of
an oxymoron Federalist 11 for instance
states that a strong military and in
particular a strong Navy was vital not
only to deter aggression but also to
secure and expand international trade
yet Federalist 26 recognizes that
military might has historically posed a
grave threat to individual liberty this
presented what seemed to be a Hobson's
choice between either a strong military
or weak military both of which would
threaten liberty over time at the hands
of foreign powers or an oppressive
central government but our founders
started away out of this dilemma the
Constitution empowered the president has
commander-in-chief to defend against
attack and take decisive military action
when necessary at the same time and
entrusted the people's representatives
in Congress with a wide range of Foreign
Affairs powers that counsel prudence
Democratic control and protection
against tyranny only Congress can raise
and support armies only Congress may
declare war and invoke
legal obligations and protections that
this legal state of international
relations confers and only Congress
regulates in foreign commerce and with
it control over important levers of
influence with foreign nations in order
to better relations exact costs and
prevent war Union widespread popular
support for international commitments a
strong and safe military these are but
three constitutional principles to be
found in our foreign policy tradition
together they help expand our nation's
options abroad they ensure a
deliberative space within which our
constitutional democracy may produce an
effective and robust foreign policy our
founders understood that a union
committed to broadly popular policies
and backed with a capable capable
military would be empowered to conduct
its foreign policy not at the point of
another nations going but in accordance
with our country's interests and
founding principles under President
Obama regrettably there's been a
considerable drift away from these
foundational principles and that drift
has contributed to a general drift of US
foreign policy even President Carter has
said I can't think of many nations in
the world where we have a better
relationship now than when he took over
Jimmy Carter our interests are
threatened our alliances are stressed
our honor is stained and our adversaries
are increasingly tempted into new
episodes of adventure ISM and aggressive
aggression both against us and our
friends and allies a most recent example
of this drift is the Iran nuclear deal
this is a major arms control agreement
with a mortal enemy an enemy with the
blood of thousands of Americans on its
hands and for whom death to America is a
foreign policy bedrock and the agreement
goes to the heart of the gravest threat
facing the world a terror sponsoring
state armed with nuclear weapons this is
precisely the type of agreement that the
founders intended to be tested and
refined by the treaty process it's
precisely the type of agreement
heading matters of war and peace that
must be supported by a widespread
consensus of the American people but the
president didn't submit the Iran nuclear
deal is a treaty from the beginning he
always intended to circumvent the
people's representatives to obligate the
u.s. to the ayatollahs by a mere
executive agreement instead of rallying
two thirds of the Senate to support the
deal and perhaps improve the deal
President Obama relied on a tiny
partisan minority to protect his
executive agreement from the judgment of
the American people and their elected
representatives this is dangerous and
nearly unprecedented executive
agreements are and shouldn't be reserved
for mostly technical matters among the
first executive agreement was a 1792
agreement between the United States and
other nations to coordinate mail
delivery executive agreements have also
been used traditionally to assign claims
and deaths between nations these issues
are low stakes and they're not breeding
grounds for armed conflict they're akin
to deciding whether we should drive our
cars on the right-hand side of the
left-hand side of the road that's why
they're not tested by a supermajority
vote of the people's representatives but
nuclear weapons agreements are different
the dividing line between which subjects
are reserved for treaties in which are
reserved for less formal scrutiny is not
precise at the margins but this isn't at
the margins in our history major arms
control agreements that bind the u.s.
and almost invariably been reached
through treaty one notable exception was
the agreed framework with North Korea in
1994 but I doubt President Obama would
like to cite the North Korea case as
precedent though surely it is and its
contempt for Congress and likely and its
ultimate nuclear outcome as well
why did President Obama ignore the
treaty clause the answer is stunning
Secretary of State John Kerry lamented
in testimony to Congress earlier this
summer that it's quote physically
impossible
in quote to get a treaty to the Senate
and these polarized times of course this
logic could apply to any politically
inconvenient part of our Constitution
not the President Obama hasn't tried
that
moreover senator her secretary Kerry
must have forgotten that his chair of
the Senate Foreign Relations Committee
he guided a nuclear arms control treaty
with Russia to ratification less than
five years ago I guess you could say
that John Kerry was for the treaty
clause before he was against it the
simple fact is that the president
ignored the Constitution because he knew
his deal would be rejected by the Senate
if subjected to a vote this disregard
for the treating make treaty making
processes the height of hubris the
president's decision to discard the
treaty process mistakes tunnel vision
for principled close-mindedness for
superior wisdom in a search for a
personal legacy for a vital national
interest this nuclear deal with Iran is
a travesty one that betrays our close
friend Israel
provides billions for Iran's campaign
for terror and paves the way for Iran to
obtain nuclear weapons capability
besides this immediate danger to our
national security the deal also damages
the foundational principle that major
foreign commitments should be backed by
a broad consensus of the people as
reflected by the Congress this episode
added to the North Korea example will
make it extremely tempting for the
future presidents to avoid the
expenditure of political capital
required to pass a treaty presidents
will be tempted to reach expedient deals
on momentous issues deals that instead
of uniting the nation will divide it
this was a key reason why 46 of my
colleagues in the Senate night released
a letter earlier this year to the
ayatollahs putting them on notice that
any push by the President to conclude
the Iran deal was a mere executive
agreement any major agreement
particularly one with the terror
sponsoring adversary must be able to win
the wide support of the American people
and passed the high bar set by the
founders in the treaty clause if not it
should be rejected
what while the Iran deal is the most
recent wound or a foreign policy
tradition a long festering one is the
decline of our military might there's a
growing disconnect between the founders
commitment to a powerful military to
secure free Commerce and peaceful
relations on the one hand and the
present state of our military on the
other our militaries face 15 years of
war in six years of repeated deep budget
cuts it's now breaking under the burden
of a mindless sequestration that
indiscriminately cuts across the board
and treats every dollar of federal
spending equally whether for defense or
for pork as a consequence our military
is facing a crisis our Navy has 260
ships the lowest level since the end of
the Cold War our Air Force is the
smallest and oldest force in our history
the Army and the Marine Corps are on
track to drop below 450,000 soldiers
190,000 Marines the bare minimum levels
our commanders say we need to fulfill
our missions these unwise cuts to our
military column to question us resolve
and security commitments it's not a
coincidence that in the span of a few
years we have seen a revisionist Russia
exert its will Ukraine and the Middle
East that radical jihadism metastasized
across the middle the Middle East and
North Africa that china is projecting
power over more and more aerial and
maritime territories and that Iran
out-negotiate us while it also spreads
chaos across the Middle East through its
clients and its proxies this picture
isn't pretty but as I said earlier the
American foreign policy tradition has a
knack for self correction for turning
the ship around and reversing past
mistakes but for that to happen we need
to look back to our to the foundational
principles of our Constitution as we
think about a new strategy for our world
to restore respect for the treaty clause
we must make every effort in the
following year to isolate and impugn the
president's nuclear deal with Iran as a
singular one-off agreement that ought
never be repeated
we must put every nation and every
business on notice that this deal is
temporary
unique they must understand that US
sanctions on Iran either through new
legislation or through a new president
will one day return we must work to
elect a new president who will rescind
the nuclear deal with Iran and who will
restore the credible threat of force
against their leaders and their nuclear
program
put simply put simply our allies in our
adversaries must understand that this
nuclear arms-control deal reached by
executive agreement is not secure
they have to understand that it's in our
interest and their interest to conclude
stable and long-lasting agreements by
way of treaty and all future president
should see that building consensus of
the advice and consent of the Senate
will afford them a genuine and lasting
legacy a restoration of the treaty
clause though must be accompanied by a
restoration of our military might
Frederick the Great said diplomacy
without arms is like music without
instruments in other words it's inert
inaudible and ineffective if we want our
diplomacy to be effective and our
agreements to be strong we must also
rebuild our military the American
tradition has never been to seek war or
to seek it first in the dispute
President Lincoln again in his first
annual message to Congress prize
diplomacy to defuse tensions with
foreign powers and to maintain our
rights and honor but in the same breath
he also called for a military buildup
aggression is according to Lincoln are
seldom made upon a nation ever ready to
defend its honor and repel insults to
ensure that we are ready to defend our
national honor today we all need
significantly more defense spending that
Congress and our president have managed
to agree upon in recent years our
current defense budget is a little more
than a political compromise which may be
appropriate for say highway funding or
tax policy but it's no way to fund a
military and it's no way to face up to
rising threats around the world Congress
and the President must return to the
foundational principle that our military
edge must not be challenged and we must
give our fighting men and women the
resources they need to deter fight and
win our Wars which will make them less
likely to happen in the first place
the founders and generations of
statesmen cents have recognized the
unique advantages with which the united
states are blessed we're a continental
nation and we enjoy the protection of
two oceans that have separated us from
historic cauldrons of conflict in Europe
and Asia we have abundant natural
resources and in industrious people
making us a powerful trading partner
around the world our people are slow to
anger but imbued with a Marshall
tradition and fighting spirit and our
democratic culture is vigorous resilient
and cherished by those people
it's these strengths that are channeled
by the Constitution into our foreign
policy tradition US strategy abroad
while not successful in every instance
has brought us from being a world
backwater to the world's superpower and
we as we think about new our future and
a strategy for today's world it would
serve as well to look back at the old
truths we must hold fast to our
foundational principles to continue our
rich foreign policy tradition and
vigorously fight any efforts to
undermine it
while each Congress and president will
have particular differences we all
ultimately will share the same goal a
world of peace and freedom of prosperity
and opportunity we have a duty to
ourselves to be true to those beliefs to
use our great power wisely on behalf of
freedom and guided by constitutional
principle as President Reagan admonished
in his speech to the British Parliament
in 1982 let us go to our strengths let
us offer hope let us tell the world
world that a new age is not only
possible but probable thank you god
bless you god bless the United States of
America
you can't see them anyway
thank you
so I want to apologize to Tom for the
inaccuracies and my introduction of him
in 1977 he was a baby in 1977 I was
courting Penelope Horton in Oxford
England and working on the Churchill
biography more important to me even than
Tom cotton tom has agreed to answer some
questions and we can't see you except
only barely and I think there are people
with microphones is that true Matthew
yeah so find somebody who's got a
question and call-out or comment but
isn't the isn't the whole treaty in the
Senate I mean the Congress did have the
opportunity to reject it I mean it's not
correct well the president didn't submit
his deal with Iran and their nuclear
program as a treaty he submitted he said
it's gonna be an executive agreement
which traditionally wouldn't require
congressional action at all earlier this
year the Congress passed a bill called
the Iran nuclear agreement review act
which in my opinion turns the
Constitution on its head rather than
requiring a two-thirds affirmative vote
of the Senate to ratify a treaty which
necessarily represents a broad
bipartisan cross regional base of
support among the American people that
bill allowed the President to move
forward and lift sanctions unless
two-thirds of the Senate voted to
override his inevitable veto that bill
was passed back in May in the Senate it
was 98 to 1 I was the one I was only 50
votes away from a majority despite my
intense lobbying efforts but
I in part because I believed it set a
bad precedent to suggest that something
like a nuclear arms control agreement
with an unrepentant enemy could be an
act could be pursued without Senate
ratification and now we're seeing the
consequences of going down this path 42
Democrats in the Senate are
filibustering our resolution of
disapproval to even prevent a vote on
the merits now in the end everyone knows
where these Democrats stand everyone
knows it is a partisan minority that's
obstructing that's obstructing the voice
of the American people who oppose this
deal two-to-one but that doesn't change
the fact that the president should have
submitted the stills the treaty and in
my opinion the Senate should have
insisted that he submit this deal as a
treaty and that we vote it down
so Larry said we take question or
comments if we are lacking those we'll
open the floor for insults as well I
don't claim any any great expertise on
Middle Eastern politics or the ability
to follow all the various partisan
groups there but let me throw out an
idea to you perhaps we should be open to
the idea of a broad anti-isis coalition
that would include Putin in Iran and
anyone else opposed to that which in my
view at least superficially seems to be
the worst of the worst in in the Middle
East the Islamic state is a grave danger
to the United States and to our citizens
our interests around the world
but in my opinion until the Islamic
state has a ballistic missile program
and thousands of centrifuges and tons of
enriched uranium the Islamic Republic of
Iran will remain an even graver threat
to the safety and security of the
American people now furthermore
furthermore to it for us to expect as
the president has suggested that Iran
may join the fight to defeat the Islamic
state is like expecting gasoline to
douse a fire it is in part
Iran and their campaign of terror and
sectarian warfare between the Shiites
who they support and the Sunnis who they
terrorize and slaughter that has given
the Islamic state the ideological basis
to rise and present themselves as the
defender of the Sunni faithful it's also
in part the president's failed policies
his hasty withdrawal from Iraq in 2011
which gave the Islamic state that the
geographic space and time it needed to
recover from its losses in Iraq and our
inaction in Syria which contributed to
that ultimately we should we have a
strong coalition of several dozen
countries that want to defeat the
Islamic state we simply don't have a
president who is willing to lead to do
what's necessary to defeat this
terrorist group I would say though that
the United States has a natural ally in
the people of Iran that's one reason why
people of Iran were an ally of the
United States through much of the Cold
War until 36 years ago there were taken
over by radical ayatollahs this is a
country that has a large middle class
that's fairly well-educated that has a
commercial spirit yet they are governed
by these radical clerics it is a country
you might say of South Koreans governed
by a few radical North Koreans in the
end the United States will not be safe
nor will an interest be safeguarded
until there is a new government in
Tehran that respects the rights of its
people and wants to be a partner with
the United States in the region senator
first of all thank you for your service
in the Iraq and Afghanistan I just have
a brief comment about the minority
Democrats who are preventing a vote on
the record up or down on the Iran
agreement they don't even seem to have
the courage of their lack of conviction
well they don't
and but but in the end in the end if the
Democrats maintain their filibuster in
the Senate the house has proceeded on a
different track which I also support
Congressman Mike Pompeo of Kansas and I
traveled to be in two months ago right
after this deal was announced to meet
with the International Atomic Energy
Committee where we learned of the two
side deals that the agency has with Iran
that the president has not obtained has
not provided to Congress as the very law
he signed requires therefore in my
opinion eliminating his power to lift
those sanctions in the end no matter no
matter what the procedural posture of
the vote in the two chambers it is
manifestly clear that a bipartisan
majority of the people's elected
representatives like a two-to-one
majority of the American people oppose
this deal making it truly unprecedented
in American history for the first time
to my knowledge the president will move
forward after the Congress has expressed
majority opposition to an international
agreement that's specifically because
the treaty Clause would have prevented
such a thing from happening in the past
or more likely would have made the
agreement more palatable to the American
people to begin with that's a that's a
stunning assessment of the current
situation and thank you for standing
alone in voting against that review Act
there has been proposed yeah there has
been proposed a procedural effort which
would identify a portion of that review
act that calls for the president to
fully disclose all of the components of
it which he has not done you have any
comments on the leadership's
unwillingness to pursue that path to
stop this what you've described as
unprecedented act well there's Mitch
McConnell just tonight proposed a third
approach which I could support as well
if the Democrats in the Senate persist
in their filibuster he would add two
amendments to the underlying bill that
would say the president doesn't have the
power under US law to lift the sanctions
until Iran one recognizes Israel's right
to exist as a Jewish state and two
releases the three or four Americans are
currently
hostage unjustly by everything
now that the house the house having
passed those resolutions last week that
says the president has not complied with
the terms of the beary law that he
signed may move forward with legal
action which I also think could be a
prudent step as well these sanctions
won't be lifted for at least four or
five months in all likelihood meaning
that there is an opportunity to have an
independent Federal Court make a ruling
on that very issue just as last week the
federal court said that the House of
Representatives had the legal authority
to move forward with the suit
challenging the president's actions
under Obamacare which are equally
without the color of law now all that
said in the end I can't imagine that
either a senator or congressman would
vote on a bill which we truly don't know
the contents of there are these two side
deals that don't go to administrative
technicalities or procedural niceties
they go to the heart of the agreement
the past nuclear work that Iran is
conducted as part of its nuclear program
the past military work that Iran has
conducted as part of its nuclear program
if we don't know what they did in the
past how can we expect inspectors to
measure what they do in the future it's
like starting a diet without knowing
your starting weight and according to
The Associated Press which were
purported to report the text of one of
those agreements Iran will be allowed to
essentially inspect itself to take its
own environmental samples to film its
own video to take its own photographs
and provide that to the IAEA in Vienna
that's akin to letting one of Larry's
students grade his own term paper it's
akin to an NFL player taking his own
urine test and sending it to Roger
Goodell and saying he's clean and ready
to play this Sunday and this is what
we're doing with Iran not a country like
Japan or South Korea or South Africa not
even a country like Libya or Ukraine
which openly gave up its nuclear weapons
but with Iran which continues to chant
every cuds day death to America and
death to Israel
senator cotton I just want to say that
in my opinion the letter that you sent
to the ayatollahs is an incredible act
of courage and that at least in my
opinion the American public ought to be
indebted to you for doing that and
essentially saying forget it this is
just Obama not the United States well
thank you thank you you know there were
46 other senators who did it with me as
well and I would point out that within
just a matter of minds President Obama
and Secretary were themselves repeating
the very point that we had made in our
letter that without ratification in the
Senate of this deal as a treaty it would
in fact be a mere executive agreement
that could be reversed by any Congress
including this one or by any future
president they were using that as a
selling point for the deal in just a
matter of minds and I just can't imagine
what was so controversial that a simple
statement of constitutional facts a
statement that even our president and
secretary Kerry ultimately acknowledged
was truthful but while we're
apportioning the blame for this
catastrophe let's not forget the role of
senators like Harry Reid there was a
time in the past when Democratic
senators that we may disagree with them
on most policy matters would have
protected the constitutional
prerogatives of their institution
someone like Bobby Byrd or scoop Jackson
who would have told the president of
their own party and no uncertain terms
and an agreement like this should have
been submitted as a treaty subject to
ratification yet Harry Reid and all the
other Democratic senators have simply
rolled over and put their own partisan
loyalty to their president ahead of
their constitutional responsibilities
and ahead of the national interest
senator as a strong believer in
constitutional term limits will you
think about running in 2000 way I run
every day at least four or five miles
down the National Mall and if God
willing if I'm still in good health I'll
do so then
I don't think any of us that we're going
to want a Republican to be a new
Republican to be running in 2020 because
I'm confident that we're gonna be
working to re-elect the Republican that
takes office in January 2017
Thank You senator cotton I would
appreciate it if you could describe why
you think the Democrats and the press
refused to recognize the precedent of
the North Korean violation of the treaty
it was negotiated by Clinton that there
were supposed to be no atomic weapons
they have tested at least three and
threatened us yesterday with nuclear
annihilation
Thomas Seoul professor at Hoover
Institution has said that if Los Angeles
and Chicago are reduced to rubble
President Obama would surrender why is
this being ignored about the precedent
with North Korea well I I think many of
these Democrats are simply soft and
gullible about the role of power in the
world that they think as Western elites
subtended to think for at least a
century maybe more that there's always
some way to reason with evil dictators
around the world that they surely can't
mean what they say
president Obama has dismissed for
instance Ayatollah Khomeini's repeated
calls for death to Israel repeated calls
for death to America the regime's
repeated aggressions around the Middle
East this said that that exact they can
actually be reasonable and rational
actors and too many Democrats and the
Senate in the house are soft in the
sense that they don't want to confront
evil force with force when necessary
which is the only way to repeal it and
they're gullible to believe that the
ayatollahs will follow this agreement
you may have noticed that on Friday Iran
just announced they had much larger than
expected stores of uranium in their
round this is a shock to everyone it's
unexpected as so much of what happened
to the Obama administration is I'm sure
irani and geologists and miners were
just out in the fields on Friday and
just discovered all this new uranium one
day after the Senate made it clear that
this deal was going to proceed of course
they've had this ace up their sleeve for
months if not years and we'll see this
repeated train
of humiliations as this deal goes
forward it seems the only thing about
history but some Democrats repeat is
failing to learn the history of the
lessons of history this is the last
question I figured that I see Larry up
there getting antsy I'm gonna try and
change the subject a bit senator you
rightfully said that the Constitution
talks about raising armies you neglected
the next phrase which to me as a retired
Submariner is important that says
Congress shall maintain a Navy comment
well well as a maritime nation our Navy
is the number one way that we should
project power overseas particularly in
the modern world of aircraft carriers
and as I mentioned the Navy is at a
historic low and now the president has
often said that well you know ships
today are more advanced than they were
you know during the Cold War certainly
than they were during World War two
which I fully concede but ship can't be
in two places at the same time and in
fact because of the radical cuts to our
military in particular the cuts to our
Navy which require major and long-term
capital investments to build carriers
and destroyers and cruisers and
submarines we are now facing the first
gap in coverage in the Persian Gulf of
an aircraft carrier in recent times what
kind of message does that send to Iran
what kind of message does that send to
our allies in the region who depend on
those carriers to help project power and
maintain a regional balance of power so
while in the end there's no there's no
substitute for the Marine Corps and the
army and ultimately forcing a foreign
adversary to bend to our will there's no
greater force for keeping the peace
insuring open trade and maintaining
American power around the world the
United States Navy
and the Navy apparently can beat the
army every year in football much to my
regret thank you all very much for
inviting me tonight again thank you all
for your veneration for our Constitution
and all this you do to support it
not bad huh he said so I've known him
you know since 1947 he's a very serious
man
so I want to make two announcements and
say a message of hope today various
people opined about whether there's any
hope or not and sometimes it depends on
what mood you're in but the truth is we
have two things in the past that are
kind of like this places where the
American Republic almost failed one was
in its founding and the other was in the
Civil War and those stories are known
and one can look and see what happened
and from that I think one can tell what
requires to be done it's not possible
because it's in the future to know if it
can be done but what requires to be done
that can be known I'm a slave to my old
friend Hugh Hewitt who assigns me
homework like I was a undergraduate
student all the time
and so he decided a few months ago that
we were gonna do all the lincoln-douglas
debates and I know a very great deal
about Abraham Lincoln and I've never
started studying and it is actually 40
years ago that I started but I'd not
read the Lincoln Douglas debate in
decades and I read him through lately
what do you find first of all the
situation was hopeless the country was
divided because a whole bunch of people
had decided that Negro slavery was a
good thing there isn't anybody in the
American Revolution who thought that
they thought the Declaration required
that we find a way to get rid of it and
so Stephen Douglas came forward and he's
a fancy-pants guy and he's rich and he's
stylish and he's everything Abraham
Lincoln is not and he proposes look
nobody has to do anything they
don't want to do it's kind of like today
what is this treaty powerful and
seductive it's because Wow all these
years we've been wrong that we have to
resist these temperance if we just let
it go everything will be fine and that's
what Douglas position was on slavery and
this lanky lawyer in disheveled clothes
wiped the floor with him and became
president United States and why was he
able to do that because God gave him the
ability to understand and explain and
there hadn't you know the first time in
American history that there was anything
like the lincoln-douglas debates was the
lincoln-douglas debates and in towns of
6,000 all of a sudden there's 20,000
people there and they've written in half
a day to sit in the Sun and watch these
guys argue because you know it was
important and because there was
something beautiful to discuss that's
the first step the first step is figure
out what's going on is there a
difference between bureaucratic and
constitutional government because if
there is we should be talking about that
all the time and since since the
retirement of Ronald Reagan we have not
done that consistently the second thing
is if you did that you would give rise
to a movement wouldn't you because
people do love freedom everybody in this
room do we love it would we fight for it
do we want our children and our
grandchildren to have it and in that
call see that is a movement that creates
itself and remember this the people that
we see identify as as a bought and paid
for by the government and agents of big
government we can always know how many
they are and there are a lot of them and
they're powerful and they're very
coherent force but only at the end how
would you count up and advance the
number of people who want to be free
because that number is infinite that's
as many as there are people the third
thing is what we just saw what does it
take to be a statesman it's very hard
Aristotle says that we all live our
lives in the choices we make when we
have to meet necessity and yet there's a
sense of Rights that governs what we do
and those two things conflict all the
time and that's where every one of us
meets the test of life everyday can we
do that with honor and build a good
character or not and he says statesmen
do it the hardest and what what are they
like did you just hear how clear and
tough that was and knowledgeable and
also restrained and careful and what he
said so you didn't it's just natural to
me it's not natural to me it's developed
as well as natural but take the tough
part you know what they said to Winston
Churchill in the middle of the Second
World War when it look hopeless Prime
Minister what are we gonna do about
Germany because you know for a hundred
years now they've led the world on a
dance and we can't seem to cope with
them in Churchill said there are fewer
than 70 million malignant Huns and some
of them are curable and the rest of them
are killable
what are we gonna do about Iran and the
point is if they interfere with the
liberties of the American people that is
a very very bad thing to do
that is a fatal thing to do if we're not
like that anymore we're finished but the
second part of it is more you know
Churchill so what did you know I hope
you know I'm just speaking for myself
right somebody who's not in a long time
and not in any position to speak for him
at all I hope he becomes president
United States but if he does the things
he said tonight are just like the things
that Winston Churchill said all his life
in other words he said a series of
things about how the executive ought not
to act arbitrarily and in that respect
his posture and Churchill's posture are
exactly like the posture of the people
who founded the country because you know
they want a war that was very
implausible for they to win and there
was the assumption that one of them
would to be a king and so their
repudiation of kingship and all forms of
arbitrary Authority was a limitation on
their power and that is the political
equivalent of sainthood and the
greatness of our country consists in the
fact that we have produced people who
are prepared to do that and we
apparently still do and I just want to
say that you know I'm in the education
business so the Reverend and all these
kids running around here you know I've
been watching these kids grow up and
they carry the principle of knowledge
and of freedom in their own hearts and
we don't put it there it's in there God
put it there and everybody's got
dad so Churchill love to say that there
is a chord in the hearts of men and if
you pluck it it will resonate strongly
and change the world I don't think we
ought to forget that and I announce that
my old friend ed Fullmer who's retired
and gone to seed is the founder of the
Heritage Foundation is becoming a
distinguished fellow of the college so
that he can teach and exercise his
greatness again
and I think Matt Spaulding and the
members of the college staff at the
Kirby Center and the members of the
college staff in Hillsdale which is of
course just one staff and their job all
of them and they're magnificent at it is
to do a fantastic job so that I can look
really good I thank them and ask them to
stand up
finally I think you and I thank you
because I live in a very distorted world
I'm surrounded by people of high quality
and character of course on the campus
come there and see you know it's just
incredible and the kids are so great
because it's easy to torture them and
they and they benefit from it it's just
a perfect world and then you people are
so pleasant and so dutiful and so
self-sacrificing and I want you to know
that we love you and we are deeply
grateful for you thank you for coming